r2 il ya une rumeur qui dit que tu es
gay tu as tu le dis dans ta chanson whip
moitié en 2013
mais qui dit quoi non mais n'y a pas eu
les gays n'ont cessé sur ton titre mais
c'est normal tu dis tu dois partir du
moment où tu dit à personne ça les gens
sans s'interroger c'est logique moi je
trouve que l'interrogation est normal
obligé de démentir ces fous satin j'ai
pas démenti les juges ont marre et posé
la question j'ai fait non c'est mentir à
la caisse voilà une rumeur qui dit que
tu te la raconte de ouf en dehors des
plateaux télé ça normal c'est faux ouais
c'est faux moi je te confirme c'est fou
une rumeur qui dit que une relation
amoureuse avec un pipole mais une rumeur
comme quoi et avec qui on coupe les
capucines à naves
non non ça en fait c'est non mais non
soit possible déjà passé j'étais déjà
mariées mais en fait c'est ça le met
plus en plus ton père il fait quoi dans
les milieux mais des jardiniers
[Rires]
à moins que ton père c'est kevin
jardiland
sinon c'est pas beaucoup mais en fait
c'est que si on avait été contactée pas
un journal people pour faire semblant
non vous verrez bien ensemble pour faire
un petit peu de promo c'est ça mais j'ai
pas compris le moi je suis même problème
avec jennifer aniston
non non c'est pas crédible au booster la
carrière de l avais besoin